[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
hope everything's okay
[Music]
in the
[Music]
[Music]
oh sure a TV
[Music]
mr. popper
[Music]
a TV
[Music]
in the cash register
[Music]
[Music]
mr. company
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry I'm just reading I'll tell you the
story I almost I almost pooped my pants
this morning
this is kind of a right we have the
nationís news it before I get into it we
have Dinesh D'Souza on the show the
quarantine is the promo code quarantine
$30 off this is Mudd Club quarantine
hashtag Mudd Club quarantine all month
were giving everything away for free in
front of the pay walls so you know what
it is that you miss behind the paywall
over that the blaze as well as three
more morning shows because we know that
you're lonely and many of you live very
sad lives I'm hearing a buzzing is that
is a fan on is it okay
yeah also the AC wasn't working we have
dinesh d'souza on the show by the way
and we have an exclusive today an
exclusive story that involves uh I think
possibly one of the most lascivious
outrageous media cover up so I can think
of in relation to the corner it's not
the virus the person that hoax about me
okay not selling any kind of colloidal
minerals but I cover up with some
stories as they relate to the virus
Gerald Morgan is here this morning yes
[Music]
how are you are you what you were
looking back like you were panicking is
something happened there Oh his
microphone time it's my job are we gonna
hit that right yeah I'm just generally
panicked about life yeah you're like him
normally or like that bug in a bug's
life that but it was the grasshopper it
was the voice of the guy from Spin City
and cousin Andy yeah in Curb Your
Enthusiasm yes I am like that right now
in the studio which as long as everyone
listening is fine by the way we'll be
taking your chat so so live chat only
available on the blaze that's the one
thing that's so exclusive to the blaze
before we get to our exclusive story
okay spoiler alert it's the fish tank
cleaner drinking lady cowboy everything
you've heard is a lie more importantly
the media knows it's a lie there's some
infant you know
so that you don't we're going to get to
all of that but first I believe we have
our traffic correspondent it's time for
the traffic report with Thomas Finnegan
[Music]
mr. Finnegan can you let us know what is
going on today as far as people with the
morning commute good morning Steven your
commute is all clear from all directions
so what I just tripped on that I just
tripped on that last sock that was piled
up for Hyundai No oh god there's a
stockpile okay one is there anything
else that we need to know about there
Finnegan ouch
yeah thank you very much
[Music]
and by the way you can go to let us
kinda calm /schedule to see yes yeah
live shows live streaming next Tuesday's
live streaming with Jean get you're not
usually an early riser there gee Morgan
I am an early right what are you talking
about i tottaly get up right I just I
just never wear PJs
Oh real just walking around naked well
that's fine the reason I'm actually
tossing is that we need to carry this
for 30 seconds while I drink this can do
the brand X oh just tape it up and go
from there that seems like a needlessly
long intro partly I might shoot myself I
might shoot myself right now on this
program that would that would make for
good TV
it would make for great TV it would
morning but I seriously want I'm fine
there's one of those things were after
here's the gun inflammation when you
walk it's like oh god yeah oh yeah
here's the brain now you could do it and
we wouldn't know for a little bit like
it would smell eventually but I mean we
don't know it's very displaying share
them if there's a very distinct
combination with human waste and cotton
and I've told that story because of my
brother in cotton no there's it's a
different Chicago right x-pac know it I
don't know the biochemical reaction that
happens hey maybe we can see Sanjay
Gupta's maybe he knows he's a doctor
right I don't think it's not so much to
protect you from getting the virus it's
to protect other people oh that's right
they're talking about masks later on as
well
we've been championing this for a long
time Origen main actually Jacko willing
so we'll help them they do jujitsu keys
and jeans they are selling masks right
now which we use here in the studio if
we're in close proximity like we have to
be doing a sketch or something right
they said you don't need masks but our
health care workers need masks and now
they're saying hey probably good idea to
wear masters so we are going oh there's
there's Brendon is that him live right
now hey Brandon even Brendon I
appreciate you wearing the mask buddy
good looks like these hard okay so this
is the fruit we don't really usually do
this in the morning story and I want to
hear your your thoughts your questions
because there's going to be a follow-up
to this this is a scoop this is an
exclusive so everyone they're getting
ready to clip this because everyone's
going to run this like it's hot and act
as though it was their idea because it's
a shame that a late-night comedy show
slash for the month of April morning
drive show is doing
that the media is not doing shameful
does everyone out there you remember the
you remember the the fish tank cleaner
lamorak wine flora coined the lady who
drank those my headphones are a little
high that might be why I'm here in the
buzzing okay the perfect everyone there
you remember the fish tank dine relation
right boy at poi cond she drink everyone
remembers the fish YouTube that come
slash Crowder bits out of its everyone
remembers the lady who drank fish tank
leader right yes koi pond cleaner
I didn't say pulley Oh koi pond cleaner
yeah your the story that we heard right
the story that we all heard and was
covered in most major news outlets both
on television in publications was that
she heard a press briefing from Donald
Trump
touting the benefits of chloroquine
medication she's medication described by
a doctor therefore because she trusted
everything Donald Trump said she and her
husband they both drank it and he died
unfortunately a tragedy she didn't and
then she had some words on mainstream
media for everyone else this was the
story this is how it was covered let's
go to the clip did you see the
president's press conference where did
you hear about and then what and then
what did you did you seek out
chloroquine okay so here's the thing and
I want let me make some of this is
absolutely 100% true that we have and
then I will offer my opinion okay the
truth is we know that it's a sham that
she hates President Donald Trump right
so at the very least this was a fake
story on that front so you probably
already know and I am going to be
looking down to make sure they get this
correctly she was obviously a prolific
Democrat don't her she donated to
Hillary Clinton in 2016 we were able to
confirm her identity and these reports
okay this has been released publicly
something I haven't seen covered
anywhere else so I don't know that
nowhere else has covered it she
specifically donated to nonprofits that
were up
progressives sort of science nonprofits
basically if you read their mission
statement it was the agenda the mission
was to counteract the anti science
agenda the anti medicine agenda of the
conservative right I thought it was to
make clear so you know that what you
don't know okay and is exclusive here
the same woman I think we have an
overlay here on social media called
President Trump a psycho Prez okay she
called him a psycho president she has a
history of violent behavior okay
so this idea is bad this idea is you
know you're picturing her the media has
presented her as a pro Trump middle
American right now she just trusted
Trump and her and her husband were
drinking fish tank cleaner holding each
other like a couple in Titanic yeah when
the truth is she wanted to divorce her
husband okay
so when she was discussing divorcing her
husband in 2001 she attacked him was
arrested was charged with domestic abuse
assault though eventually she was found
not guilty she still talked about
wanting to divorce him in 2012 and said
quote I am furious
all the time she reiterated it in a 2013
court case now some of this has been
tweeted out okay some of this
information has been tweeted out but we
were able to confirm some of these other
sources with two separate two other
these other claims of two separate
sources okay one of them being a lawsuit
that people sort of covered but they
miss the assault case where she filed
against a company believed it was John
Deere tractor where she worked for
before I don't know why exactly why she
sued them but that's where the assault
was mentioned because her real name
wasn't used in any of the stories there
we go okay and then the other one was we
have some exclusive access to social
media and I had this corroborated with
some folks in law enforcement I looked
it up so she filed for chapter I know
when she felt for bankruptcy some
information that's not necessarily
relevant but it did serve to confirm
this case now here's the deal we made
sure to try and redact all the names I
obviously don't want to Doc's anyone so
please nobody out there try and Docs or
figure anything out but the media knows
this woman's name yeah so they went out
and they didn't cover her name they just
covered the story this lady who who was
a president Trump supporter drank fish
tank cleaner because Donald Trump is
praising an unverified unproven a
non-antibiotic what is it I guess an
antiviral something later Ruby aunty
Beryl right yeah he's been he's been
basically touting the benefits of this
anti coronavirus drug the story was poor
old lady and husband who love each other
and love Trump died the media meaning
New York Times ABC NBC by the way I'm
going to be calling every single one of
them after the show so I want you to
send in numbers heads of News people who
you think would be in charge of these
stories or who ran these stories because
they knew this woman's name yeah
they claimed they were withholding it
due to you know wanting to keep her
anonymous in which case they knew that
she wanted to divorce her husband they
knew that she hated President Donald
Trump and they knew that at least part
of this was a shame and that his
journalistic malpractice or ABC NBC CBS
all of these major news outlets
Washington Post didn't know her name in
which case you did not verify or vet
your anonymous source which is
journalistic malpractice and you did
this to try and alter the face of an
election by the way because that's in
the central issue that Donald Trump
hasn't handled this properly and this
was a linchpin for a lot of it he's
going out there making here's Donald
Trump anti-science again and you found a
woman who gave to Hillary Clinton and
gave to conservatives are anti science
nonprofits and something else okay so
all of this we know beyond any shadow of
a doubt right now was this sham to try
and harm the president in by proxy all
conservatives but but do you know what
else this means this is speculation this
is speculation
I think this [ __ ] is the new Carole
Baskin I think I agree she was husband
on long history of it she wanted to
divorce him she clearly hated Trump and
only her husband died I think he was
having his evening Manhattan and didn't
realize it was mixed with a little bit
of koi food well I think what she did is
she walked over and said hey honey I
already took my dose it's time for your
suicide pact and his wasn't off the side
of the mouth and she didn't actually saw
it so I and the only reason that we're
digging into something like this is that
this story on its face made no sense
whatsoever right well no that's Donald
Trump well Donald Trump was not pitching
that people should be taking chloric on
right so that was the fact he was just
saying that that is some
that might be beneficial these people
could not possibly have come up with a
crazier story like yeah we both drank
fish tank cleaner because it had one
ingredient in it much less everything
else in it that might help us none of
these things really lined up that's why
we're digging into it because it's just
it just doesn't make sense
what anybody to do it and I think it's
an obvious it's an absurd story and it's
really sad that her husband died but
here's a magic can you imagine if there
was even a whiff of an idea that someone
killed his wife in order to indict
Barack Obama said you know I really
supported Barack Obama and I believed
that he didn't he didn't have a brother
who was in Kenya to live in a shanty I
didn't believe that until that man
showed up and and poisoned my wife and
now I think you shouldn't go for Barack
Obama and then we find out right that he
poisoned his wife you know I'm not
saying that's the case but I do think
there should actually be some kind of an
investigation here for criminal activity
I don't know if it's not only fraud but
speculation a potential murder I think
it's really really fishy and I want
everyone out there to blast this as far
as you can send us send me on twitter at
s crowd or any stories that you've seen
or watched well seen or watch same thing
seen or read and then so watch or read
sorry I'm very tired and I almost shat
myself who've covered this story because
I am going to run down a list and call
each and every one of them yes and find
out which version of journalistic
malpractice will it play here because it
is one or the other and hopefully
someone will follow this this trail and
see what happened to the husband so
let's go to some chat really quickly I
don't know if people are people losing
their minds over this right now because
I lost mine yesterday I didn't get any
sleep could be why I pooped myself along
with the bad shrimp I didn't put myself
I almost did I'll tell you the story
that almost took care of it is there any
chat to go to guys yes by the way you
should use chatter we do not have names
yet or you know just put your own
username in there of course hit the
notification bell if you are not
subscribed and hit all notifications so
that you will be aware of everything
that goes up and it's every day at 9:00
p.m. on weekdays and for the month of
April enter the promo code quarantine
$30 off subscribe to Crowder pets to you
get all kinds of exclusive content
but say you know obviously enough no not
enough stop there's more digging that
needs to go in here but what do you
actually think will happen do you think
the media will do anything about this or
is this like one of the Cavanaugh
witnesses that just magically comes up
says something wrong we hear to the
ether I'm hoping there's more to this
because it involves a pandemic that
affects everybody yeah everybody and
especially because chloroquine could be
we are finding out now that it could be
a medical miracle not a cure a medical
miracle as a therapeutic as reparation
treatment right now to people who are
suffering suffering and potentially
dying killed her husband we do have a
chat that someone related so so first
thanks for exposing the lies and all
this is a Joe Dirt
on that note however how do we share
what sources like you and other members
of the blaze and even Daily wire anytime
I use clips from any right-wing source
my liberal friends dismiss and say they
do not count it doesn't count then
there's nothing I can do for you however
unlike the Young Turks or NBC ABC CBS
you just saw the overlays now unlike
will redo the evening show where we
actually can go in and post and we make
sure that we actually provide the link
code on you on the image you're just
gonna have to do a little bit of digging
yourself but they're all brought up
right here I can tell you right now that
some of these come from oh wait no some
of these are actually two exclusive
screenshots so but they have been
verified right well I would not come out
and give you information I am well you
can never be hundred percent confident
99.999999 9 percent sure that this is
the person and that this is the course
of action well the so-called objective
news sources are the ones who were doing
all this fake work ahead of time so yeah
it's it's basically going on to show
that we can't trust those guys right so
if we pretend like the people who are
the so-called right-wing biased sites
are the problem no it's actually the
reverse and I would you want to shout
out to to reg the band at our researcher
who's brilliant he's obese he's a band
is so good he found this so I want to
say the exclusive information none of
that is me I basically said hey reg I
have a hunch and then he did the rest of
that good work it will be amazing to if
no one in the media covers this that
this woman it's enough that the woman
was anti-trump and pro
because again her message out there's we
trusted the president right and no one
else should ever do that she is
advocating against voting for the
president yeah absolutely
I'm not sure the legality of that and
I've got to emit what how many billions
of dollars can we bring that up maybe
you maybe reg confundus what's the
what's the budget for CNN for ABC NBC
CBS I don't know exactly what the
research budget is but if you look at
the total budget of the media industry
or even if it's billions it's billions
of dollars well in the meantime we got
another chant that says the problem with
this does a lot of people already don't
trust the media so even if they did
cover it up how are they going to be
held accountable in that all I can do is
make some phone calls at this point and
see and then and then hopefully rally
the information back to you hopefully
next morning on Good Morning mug Club
because I'm not I mean I'm not an FBI
agent what would I tell you what this
would this seems like something that
would go beyond local law enforcement
and that's the challenge it's not like
someone you know spray-painted your yard
right I think this probably all ends up
just being lost like you said kind of
disappearing into the ether
unfortunately because one we have much
you know much bigger things going on
right now the people's attention will be
focused on but this is big when it comes
to the media doing something that is
obviously designed to her Trump and like
you said even if they didn't know
they're still wrong for doing it it's
like everybody who comes out and says I
did something that the president said to
do and it hurt me or the president lied
to me or the president did this to me
they're running to them with a camera to
microphone and saying here's the leading
question where did the president touch
you yes exactly let the record show he
said on my pee pee with the chlorophyll
yes yes that's exactly what's happening
I was interviewing her was like okay
well where did you get the information I
want to show this right now see it and
they finally got one right
hire Kovac death 19 rig New Orleans may
be caused by underlying health issues
let's bring up the number I think it was
a 99 percent and then if you add enough
in New York I believe it was 96 percent
let us know when you have that of the
pre-existing conditions yeah maybe a 96
percent causation here yeah
hey but it's all got to be called called
Cova deaths when this when this filters
out we're gonna be looking and I talked
to my wife about this last night one to
two percent I think is what the number
will actually be because right was you
have a point point four percent in
Germany mortality rate and you having
ten percent in Italy that doesn't make
sense the populations yes they're
different I understand that but they're
not that different right that's
significantly different so I think right
now what you're suggesting it's the
Aryan bloodlines no on the show know
that the six for blonde blue-eyed man
espousing Aryan I don't I don't think
that's why I don't think that's why I
don't either I would never say that did
you say guineas I didn't did you call me
disgusting Jarrell thank God we're live
and people can hear for themselves
what's going on there's not a bleep
bleep what's funny is I have to pick the
right wrong racist term so that
YouTube's remove it right yeah my boxing
coaches of Italian that's so literally
every time we show up all he's like I
you've how you doing you frickin frog as
French gambling I don't know you filthy
what what's going on let's go hit the
myths Oh although if you get into Sicily
and you he doesn't like it then they
talk about the Moors really yeah the
more yeah but it's when you punch each
other he would destroy a boxing team my
god and he basically just shows me how
to suck less alright the way just to
make sure that we have a recap of this
week since it's Friday and anything that
we've missed or gotten incorrectly our
senior news correspondent
Brody McBride again is going to be here
with the Morning Report is time for
morning-after with Brautigan
all right mr. Brautigan how are you sir
okay okay yes so with all the focus on
unemployment I have one story about one
guy who didn't get a new job a singer
Jackson Brown apparently just signed an
endorsement deal with Corona no no okay
huh slow down there but again he no he
actually Jackson Browne was he was
tested positive for Corona deposit for
the coronavirus Brautigan it's not a
good beer I wouldn't call it a virus
okay no no Jackson Brown announced that
he tested positive for do anything else
on the pandemic there Brautigan okay
we're all aware of the Internet yeah
yeah yes they were upset over doctor who
when they teamed with the Chinese
government to like the night Taiwan over
no no no what no que no who is who is
the World Health Organization yeah it
was a doctor from who run again are you
sure about that guys ever since they got
a girl doctor it's been all woken crap
you know actually quarterblack knows
what's up hey no no no Brian no no no no
okay these are both old stories
Brautigan this isn't necessarily a recap
from this week on is there anything more
anything more recent probably what's
going on with a proposal racing yes
cardi B you know cardi B she's vaguely
familiar
okay well surely she endorsed a
candidate and said she was on Team Joe
but apparently now she's saying she was
just friend and a too cute man eat you
have it overlay is that I don't know
she's not sure yet here now first off
it's yeah I think he means Maddie and
you have the wrong Joe Brautigan that's
that's Joe exotic when she says team Joe
right right he's running for president
oh did you yet okay he ran he ran for
president five years ago spoiler alert
Brautigan what Joe Biden he's the one
running for Brett yeah the different one
running for president twenty twenty
different guys oh wait who's that know
me have you been drinking no I'm
supporting our response or a black rifle
bourbon no no no no no black rifle
coffee bourbon is a classification of
coffee bean it's actually a gray
you know what just that's fine that's
not let him know that's black rival
coffee calm slash Crowder enter the
promo code router you get 20% off it is
fantastic coffee actually doing give up
a buy back give it back to emergency
responders very nice by the way that
went about as well as I expected really
him yeah it went better than I I knew
that I was taking a risk you were you
really were like sitting in that chair
right now with your stomach yes yeah
I'll talk about that in a little bit
what's the next drawer we have to get to
here it's a it's the morning suite oh
okay car to here's some of yeah we do
have a story about about the Blasio but
before I get to that here's one thing to
we've talked about this audio Wade and
in jail those people who run businesses
we talked about this last time that the
untargeted stimulus relief bill and I
understand that a lot of businesses
small businesses are being helped right
now with with with effect effectively
money giveaways and you know increasing
the ability and the availability of
loans the ability for banks to loan and
the availability of loans sorry I don't
want to talk very quickly the ability to
wait yeah the data would suggest if I so
here's something that people don't this
is why I'm so against universal basic
income and I get a lot of letters from
you guys and you guys talk in the chat
and and by the way Sutton's based ciders
that's my uncle cidery they have had
they've really had a struggle it's a
small cider in northern Michigan if you
like hard cider it's the best they've
won international awards for their state
of the cherry and ginger I think it's
Upton's based ciders calm if you want to
support a small business story but I did
I did read a couple of stories from
small business owners out there
particularly having the lower wage
employees right now this is why I'm
against universal basic income a lot of
people haven't taken this into account
when they say give it directly to the
workers don't give it to businesses in
the assume that businesses are all big
businesses we have 12 employees by the
way the classification for a small
business from the government I believe
is under 500 so for this for the we have
15 employees sorry we have 8 in the
office that join right now
and 12 who are usually in the office
there are a lot of workers right now
with businesses who are not coming in to
work because they're receiving a check
this is anecdotal we do not have numbers
on this right now we won't have numbers
for probably several months but this is
one of those things that you hear a lot
people say oh you really think that if
you give everybody a thousand a month or
if you give everyone 1200 or 1700 if
they have a they have a wife or a
codependent don't know how much with
wives versus children so wife the
codependent depends on the kind of
sandwich you mix so people say you think
they're gonna stop working yes yes there
are a lot of people unfortunately who
want to simply remain comfortable and
they will forego the hard work as long
as they make enough look at what happens
in Native American reservations it's not
a federal check but they sue the
government over the land and then of
course they get a check in perpetuity a
lot of these people it's destroyed the
community and this is actually this is
really bad long term for the American
economy here's why people don't show up
to work because they're getting the
check and this is really more so affects
low-wage workers we'll be doing some
cash giveaways just like the Joker in
the Michael Keaton game and the only one
that counts
because whatever money I don't I don't
really need it I don't know what my wife
and I are getting but I'm not gonna I'm
gonna give it away so send in your chat
send me a reason send me a video as to
why you deserve the money because we
want to give it to someone who who needs
it I don't need a I'm grateful people
here are paid significantly more than
minimum wage I don't believe in a
minimum wage but I believe in paying my
employees more than a minimum wage but
for you guys 1,200 a month would not be
nearly enough to replace your income no
no I'm right and if anyone wants to
leave and not work and take 1,200 a
month we've had we've talked about
open-door policy but it is a revolving
door policy if someone else is going to
come in and work right now I hope that I
wish you well and hopefully we'll have
room when you guys come back but people
who are making the lower end of the pay
scale comfort is good enough and what is
that what does that do
oh maybe that employee is taking care
but why is it more important to take
care of a business that it can ensure
continued employment because when these
employees don't come and guess what now
you can't have the health benefits the
retirement benefits all of a sudden the
working vacations go away and the
business that will employ you once that
check stops it looks like it's going to
be ten weeks I think right now guess
what you're out of luck unfortunately
there are a lot of people in this
country who are so short-sighted
that if you give them money and this is
something to people always talk about
other business owners they're greedy
what could possibly be more greedy than
taking your money and screwing the
person who paid you money
years this is happening across the
country right now yeah well especially
with unemployment being that the dollar
amount going so much higher than it has
been in the past it's 48 thousand
dollars per year to be on unemployment
right now who would have thought that
woody robust economy would bite us in
the end yeah no kidding right so a
48,000 Trumpler
should have followed the obama plan we'd
be better off in the pandemic a little
bit right so I think what you're saying
is that a lot of people think if you
just give people money that they'll be
better off to be able to buy goods and
services but as a business owner like
you said I've had conversations with
other business owners and we're like the
money coming to the business is
fantastic the payroll protection plan
that stuff really helps out right and
this is so different like you said the
government shut this down this wasn't
the economy crashing the government
actually closed your business and said
hey we're sorry we have to close your
business right and if they keep business
is going very different it's fantastic
and people being on unemployment for
forty eight thousand dollars a year
there's gonna be a lot of people don't
want to come back it is absolute
insanity yeah and and that that was one
of the things that Ted Cruz was saying
senator Cruz on the on the this whole
debate saying look hold on like I know
we need to increase it a little bit
maybe for a short period of time but
don't do it indefinitely let's draw a
parallel here okay so you you have some
employees and you have some people who
are more like des raters who are paid
less here because it's a specialized
position yeah it's a different deal
apply for Golden Tickets know that the
pay is significantly above the national
average here let's say you have someone
who's only making twenty thousand a year
twenty five thousand right could you
picture a scenario where that person
says I'll take a pay cut of a few
thousand but I can do whatever I want
all day long actually they're not gonna
take any pickups so what you're talking
about is stimulus stimulus check right
the 1200 no no that's what that is what
I'm talking about as far as with
businesses who've been employing people
right now and I didn't even think about
this until I read dozens of stories from
people sending this in yeah well and you
can I can furlough somebody right now so
take that 20,000 I don't have one but if
I had somebody making 20,000 not fire
them furlough them I could furlough that
person which means at some point I'll
rehire them so they don't actually have
to go out and look for a job where I can
just sit on unemployment as long as I
keep them they're making $48,000 a year
not because that's Bossier right Oh
so that's probably - women's 4000 what
happening with these business owners
these people aren't just leaving and
taking a check they might be furloughed
or they're getting they're getting for
double dipping and farlows better
because that says you're eventually
going to rehire the
but let me be very clear it's just
unemployment it's 40 by the way so take
the furthest on the plan can anyone else
agree with me that that's a scam further
play for low furlough for prisoners I
didn't know yeah furlough for prison I
am offended people who are like low
security risk prisoners they can go home
for a bed I think it's good was it Gotti
who did that - he's not a violent
offender really I know John got well I
don't think it directly connected but
there was a John Travolta mobster film
and I remember talking about furloughs a
long time ago and I was watching it
there's a famous mobster you guys can
let me know we can bring this up there I
don't know if it was Gotti who was on
furlough said like yeah yeah I know
you're in prison you have a to whatever
20-year sentence but on weekends you
know you go to Chuck E Cheese actually I
think I've heard of this with actual
murders it happened with murders and
they got out on the weekend and then
they killed more people on the weekends
on the weekend but it was only a weekend
thing ya know I go that's my weekend
things do we kill people you know my job
we can bring that up I'm sure we can
have a resource folks
the media I don't have it in front of me
but we'll get it pulled up okay I've got
imagine it's billions of dollars all
right here's another story that's been
pretty big Bill DeBlasio he says that
he's very concerned about anti-gay
evangelical group running he refers to
it as led by the virulent li anti LGBTQ
and Islamophobic preacher Franklin
Graham so this has been everywhere right
now Samaritan's Purse yeah let's be
clear this is a religious nonprofit and
as much as people like to say church
leaders tax-exempt status really how
much how much do you help your community
how much do you give to charity right
people don't realize that a hue the bulk
of humanitarian work is carried out by
private organizations and local churches
and local churches so Samaritans perch
perch perch they got a perverse managing
a 60 bed respiratory care unit and
they're handling overflow patients right
now for Mount Sinai now I want to be
really clear about this organization
before I get into something that will
piss people off they provided medical
humanitarian care all kinds of countries
you have Haiti earthquake hurricane
natural disasters pandemics Darfur
Uganda they were also actually they were
one of only two organizations to go to
Liberia during the Ebola outbreak that
was a 50% death right around zero it was
crazy so think about this for a second
while we're all and obviously everyone
deserves praise who's helping right now
of course but while we have stories and
listicles on BuzzFeed and Vox about the
frontline medical workers who've worked
a 12-hour shift and that is tough and
they're overburdened and thank you for
some reason because we hate the
religious affiliation of Franklin Graham
we don't talk about the fact that a 50%
death rate disease virus Ebola 50% death
rate in Liberia that they went out and
helped yeah
that isn't Krypton no matter where you
line up on religion or Franklin Graham
that should be a good thing now let's
get to Franklin Graham I read the exact
quote which I think we can bring up he
was very clear Franklin Graham and
saying I didn't have a problem with
religious followers of Islam this is not
an indictment on all of them but I do
have a problem with the religion I do
have a problem with the teaching I have
a problem with Sharia law how its
implemented how they treat their women I
believe that is wicked and evil a quote
to that extent we have a source that we
can bring up it was very very clear so
of course this article I think from
Gotham has been very upsetting has been
covered everywhere Franklin Graham
Islamophobic called Islam wicked and
evil he called certain portions of Islam
wicked and evil and here's something
just like you know what maybe this
pandemic is maybe a little bolder and I
don't really care if I get removed
because mug Club thank you so much for
joining up promo code quarantine $30 um
not all followers not all Muslims
but Mohammed and the founding teachings
of it yeah you know I'll say you wicked
and evil I would yeah I think all your
practicing Christians have to believe
that what Mohammed specifically and some
writings and hadith espoused are wicked
and evil let me explain to you why okay
so let's get to um obviously the idea
that the Bible warns against false
prophets right I think if a verse I
don't want to read revelations one eight
nine if you want actually go fact check
this and go read the verse that's great
they warn against false prophets
especially anyone who preaches teachings
that supersede what is written in the
Bible from Genesis to revelations in
other words if these teachings say no no
erase what happened there were changing
the rules that is considered biblically
evil yeah so it's very clear does and
that's where we've talked about other
cults they do that right they take the
Bible say yeah it's listed and they
twist it and they add to it did Muhammad
do that now I'm not saying all Muslims I
want to be clear I'm talking about these
teachings from a Christian ideology from
a theological standpoint Abraham this is
a big one Abraham you know he went up to
the went up to the mountain had his son
yes but they actually Muslims actually
in particular this is they say that
Ishmael or so they don't believe it was
Isaac who was one up to be sacrificed no
he was now they believe that the texts
were perverted and distorted by scribes
in other words everything after Abraham
Mohammed everything after Abraham before
Mohammed is not really reliable and by
the way everyone who was just kind of
jewy so that's a dog whistle in that
case does that not kind of give you an
idea as to where maybe some of the
anti-semitism which has arisen in the
Islamic world for the most part always
where if you believe that the Jews and
the Christians lied or twisted warped
everything passed to sacrifice the non
sacrifice of Abraham the blessing of the
first child that's a big deal that is
evil because guess what it's accusing
Christians and Jews of being evil right
you know and I think it's a pretty
simple equation right if you have a one
true God and He has set up a kind of a
system right and he sends his son and
this is God in the flesh and he dies for
you and this is the way to heaven than
that so he says right so the claims that
are made in Christianity leave no room
for other claims to be made right right
by their selves that is the only thing
that can be either that or God is a liar
that's the only choice that we have and
so Islam comes along and says no there's
another way that's evil well that's
foreign think to the Islamic faith the
Islamic religion I want to say views all
of the people Jesus all the people who
came before Muhammad as basically sort
of formative Muslims yes bad Moses they
don't beautiful view them as Christians
because they believe that Islam is the
one true faith and you think I don't
have a problem with that I want to be
clear when people say all religions tell
a story go read
Aesop you [ __ ] who cares follow a
religion because of a story that they
taught me an MRE in Canada moral
religious education and a state-funded
Catholic in a provincial II funded
Catholic school you do the math
separation of church and state what
so that's what they taught all religions
tell a story okay well then let's look
at the story you look at the story of of
Jesus it's listen there was a law this
got God in the flesh came down to
fulfill the law and free you in a lot of
ways from the shackles of your sin
that's kind of a recap that's the
Clinton Notes version that's the
elevator that's the elevator pitch of
Jesus Christ yeah elevator pitch from
Muhammad everything that guy said is
[ __ ] okay and let me get to the
really important so kill that guy yeah
if you're a Christian okay if you're a
Christian out there
I want again this is important because
words matter what can an evil if you're
a Christian and someone were to come up
to you right now and say Jesus never
died in was resurrected that's a lie
that never happened
that's about as close to the
unforgivable sin as described in the
Bible as you can get in modern times
that's what Islam believes they deny the
resurrection of Jesus Christ now whether
you believe it or not that's fine but
from a Christian worldview from a
Christian theological world you a
prophet who come who arrives after the
book of Revelation who adds to the text
and say by the way ignore that because
the son of God God in the flesh didn't
die the resurrection is a sham you would
have to say that's evil right yeah and I
don't think it's a stretch for somebody
to to say I'm a Christian and I believe
that faiths that try to take you away
from God or evil like that's an evil
thing to do I don't have a problem with
with the Muslim scholars saying I'm a
Muslim and I bet that your worldview is
trying to draw people in from the one
true prophet Muhammad and that you're
evil like you know there's a big
contrast between Jesus and Muhammad if
they say listen we follow uh we follow a
serial warlord who who married a six
year old but only copulated when she was
nine was a very powerful man a man who
led a political movement and social
upheaval very violently and you follow a
carpenter who you know never got laid I
think you guys are wrong if I said that
to me I would say I disagree but I think
that worldview income
dress with mine is kind of wicked now
what get in the cool away let the skater
kids sake anybody this way too if if an
Islamic organization came and set up 60
beds in Central Park right now and said
hey we're here to help I'd say thank God
that's a good question where are the
Islamic states right now where are they
oh no where are they sending the masks
by the way I know we do we have to Nash
do we have them uh we do okay yeah well
bring them on soon but um I do want to
also note by the way 3m screw you guys
were there they're the ones who are
building masks and now that turns out
they've been shipping them whole country
overseas and here's a good this is where
Donald Trump is invokes a defense
production act and this is what I will
say in pandemics everyone becomes a
nationalist right okay in MX everyone is
a nationalist because people don't want
to see Americans die it's not that we
don't care about people in Korea Germany
Italy but we have to take care of our
own
really and I do think it's appropriate
if you need to invoke the defense
production Act if a company like 3m says
hey we're gonna make mass we're gonna
get them to you American people and say
oh sorry our contracts are actually with
other countries right now because they
came in and they bid higher no no if the
American taxpayer in any way is helping
to keep you afloat and you get some kind
of a government contract right now you
do not get to go seek a higher profit
elsewhere because you made this isn't
about socialism this is about honoring
your agreement 3m and you said you were
gonna build masks to help American
workers that's the kind of America first
that I'm behind that's the kind of
America first that we're talking about
that's the kind of nationalism that
we're talking about and it has nothing
to do with Edie furlong and ash huasteca
with Elliott Gould in golden gold well I
don't know I don't know that's where the
point is nationalism doesn't mean white
nationalism right 3m do the right thing
and I hope the president Trump kicks
your ass if you don't I like that and if
they have if they have a factory in
Germany that wants to produce some for
Germany fine fantastic know that us
first well know if they have a faster in
here it's an American company yeah it's
as far as I understand it an American
company they certainly make their
profits in the United States they came
out for the good you don't get to
benefit from the goodwill of Americans
right yeah is it of a boycott a bike
everyone I guarantee cuz myself I said
you know what I'm gonna go get some
sticky strips for the wall I don't even
have any paintings I don't like art but
I think I wanna support the 3m support
you don't get to benefit from that
goodwill and then say oh but we're
international no no America first and
everyone right now needs to be a
nationalist in that sense not a racist
one it has nothing to do with racism
just to prove it a token a token
minority of Lehigh was a guest on right
now his new book is I want to make sure
that I get this right well you know what
he can tell us about his new book it is
the United States of socialism mr. de
souza how are you sir hey thank you very
much I want to be clear since you have
more melanin in your skin do you believe
that anything I just said regarding
nationalism in this pandemic was racial
supremacy yeah I think it's interesting
how there's been an effort to spin this
in racial terms and I think that it
actually reflects this this kind of new
socialism we could call it and what I
mean by that is simply that socialism
traditionally was all about class the
rich and the poor the worker is in the
capitalists right but now we have this I
call it identity socialism and what I
mean by that is socialism is now married
to the politics of race and gender and
sexual orientation and immigration and
so socialism today's would have been
unrecognizable to Marx right because
it's socialism married to this new
identity politics
yeah and that must be frustrating for
you mr. D'Souza because one thing you
know we hear about the white black thing
a whole lot in the United States and I
don't think I'm letting the cat out of
the bag when I say that you're you were
you're originally from India your family
your lineage and I've met some Indians
who are far darker than black people
they don't seem to be included in that
mix is that generally South Indians
generally but not entirely the India
runs the whole spectrum if you look at
the Indian Bollywood actresses they look
basically white right and that but on
the other hand you've got Indians who
are completely dark now I think here
it's a boy
to make a distinction between race and
skin color because right the Indians can
be dark-skinned without being negroid in
a racial sense right but racist would
treat them the same way is what I'm
saying if everyone in this country was a
racist they would look I mean if you
compare Drake for example to there was a
guy Prakash who is a server at my
favorite locally he's very very dark and
I'm like wait wait someone call ice-t if
there's a real racist he would treat him
just as poorly but we don't hear the
same it doesn't seem like Indian
Americans have the same kind of
political clout in voice and that seems
important especially when we're talking
about identity politics with socialism
right now well the other thing is if you
go to India India has now become I would
say one of the most Pro American
countries in the world I know so that
there's very wide pro-western and
pro-democracy Loney dualism is horrible
India would have been a fabulously rich
country were not for colonialism all of
this kind of blow ba Shin has subsided
you have a small clack of socialists who
still say this kind of stuff but by and
large they're they're ridiculed by the
rest can I ask you - by the way audio
Wade there just loves Democrats I don't
know why maybe you can shoot him
straight but why is it that they're so
I've noticed this with other countries
having been raised in Canada there was a
huge rash of anti-americanism in Canada
and that's pretty obvious because
they're jealous this is a land of really
cool stuff Canada silly and then I've
noticed though the two groups of people
who are most pro-american this is
anecdotal you would probably have the
data on it have been Indians and for
some reason Australians a lot of the
time okay why do you think that is with
Indians why are they so Pro America and
Western civilization because it seems
like a lot of I mean you look at the
yogi culture here the vegan ultra-left
culture they're often espousing what
they view as as Indian sort of values
right the the the in the leftist in
America who's pursuing India and thinks
India is cool because of you know Hari
Krishna and because of all this stuff
they're chasing in India that the
Indians are now running away from right
they're pursuing an Indian dream that
Indians don't have anymore Indians by
and large want the American dream now
when I was growing up I grew up under
socialism it wasn't totalitarian
socialism it was democratic socialism
and the three things I remember the most
about it they're number one first of all
we had a seven-year wait to get a phone
we never had Bhama the lady would have
been pissed he would have been pissed
hey what do you think the ration card
and see now when we go into a grocery
store and they tell you you can only buy
you know one roll of toilet paper that's
a little temporary whiff of what it was
like growing up in a socialist country
where it's a real whip yeah they'll tell
you you know you can only buy so much
cooking oil you can only buy so much
rice and the third is just corruption at
every level of government I mean you
have to pay people under the table all
the time right it's corruption here but
not in the same way so I think Indians
who a whole generation of Indians are my
age fled India my brother went to see
other people went to Dubai a third group
of people went to Canada and Australia a
fourth group came to the United States
what did you say that your brother went
to see like he my brother went to my
brother went as a cadet on a merchant
marine ship and he basically started out
of Singapore and he made his life he
became a captain is he a Scientologist
no let it that way okay he's not a
Scientologist though right not that I
see goodbye just the the Native American
not Indian Native American you know the
whole broadcast would be stopped
I think that's I do want to say cuz we
don't have a lot of time and I
appreciate making the time finish but I
think it's very important and you do a
very good job of this delineating
between totalitarian socialism and what
they call or brand democratic socialism
because it still is socialism and I've
experienced this in Quebec obviously I
would assume to a lesser degree than
India but it still is a 52% income tax
rate you still are talking about a
socialized health care system where yeah
listen now they opened it up to
privatization in 2005 but when my mom
needed an MRI and they had fewer MRI
machine
in the whole country than they had I
think in the state of Vermont back then
if you pay a few hundred dollars under
the table you can get an MRI within a
couple months as opposed to fourteen so
I think it's important for people who've
experienced that to be out there
speaking to to their experiences yeah I
mean in some ways at the level of pure
principled democratic socialism differs
from totalitarian socialism kind of like
gang-rape differs from individual rate I
mean look this way I'll explain that and
also by the way it reminds me the audio
lid we need to tell that story about the
the elephant seal rails because that we
were talking about before is continue
with your rape analogy mr. okay in both
cases the coercion whether the coercion
comes from one guy or from a majority
imagine you have a group of people they
all have one marble right and one guy
has ten marbles so authoritarian
socialism means that one guy gets to
grab the guy who has ten marbles take
his marbles
yes democratic socialism a majority of
the people with one marble all decide to
use the same level of force but use the
fact that a majority of them have
decided to confiscate the other guys in
both cases the other guy is deprived of
his property right in one case is done
by one guy in the other case it's done
by force right a group claiming the
legitimacy of the majority and that's my
point is yeah yeah sense from the point
of view of principle there's no
fundamental difference as a confiscation
in both cases there's force employed in
both cases and an injustice is done in
Borghese exactly and that's why it's
very important to understand the idea of
private property and constitutional
rights like you said I think it's a
brilliant analogy in one case somebody
takes the marble in the other case the
nine marbles take the remaining marble
and if Joe Biden were at the helm he'd
just lose them there would be no
bangarang all right it is the Nestor's
of the book I believe is available for
pre-order June 2nd it's gonna be out on
June 2nd United States of socialism
correct
yes you can pre-order it now but it
won't be in stores until later so I'm
just thinking through and you know
there's a what's strange about it now is
to mean when you go into stores and
they're empty my wife's from Venezuela
so she's been telling me about the empty
stores and in in Venezuela now for years
yeah but I never knew what that felt
like but now a little bit with this
strange virus situation we're getting a
preview of what normal life is like in
socialist countries yes that being said
in your private life
take advantage during this pandemic
because if she's from Venezuela that's
one less hungry mouths to feed
dinesh d'souza we must go the book is
united states of socialism available for
pre-order June 2nd we're gonna go to a
short commercial break after this but we
were talking about this before the break
you guys can let Dinesh go I think now
the elephant seals yes yes I was
watching this documentary called the
riot and the dance on Amazon Prime right
and I knew that you were into animals so
I figured I'd tell you this story it was
just this particular anyway so elephant
seals yeah they're the ones with these
weird gelatinous noses that let's fall
down in their mouths but yeah in
elephant seal populations there is no
consensual sex
there is only rape but but they're also
only red there's only rape but they're
also super jealous of each other so like
one guy like seven females that he comes
here oh he constantly rapes and then so
but if other if another elephant seal
comes and rapes one of his female rape
all the time and then so they yeah and
so in this documentary there's one where
like the this elephant seal is raping
another guys rape victim yes and then
you see in the shot this other elephant
seal coming and just like in our yeah
charging at him with this weird Matt
like weird nose and they get in this
disgusting looking fight and then the
determine who gets to Rhea exact
in the female I'm also and you've heard
me when I did this at the river
plantation Country Club when I would
stand up what am i a bit used to be like
about how horrible animals are because
you'll see these animal rights activists
say well I never see animals treat each
other the way humans do we treated each
other more amazing it really is
something you actually could you try to
explain to someone anyone an animal
rights activist that's scenario with
humans like no this is a relationship
like oh okay so this guy's a polygamist
not exactly a bunch women I don't know
that he pays their room and board like a
polygamists so much as when he feels
like it and he can find them he rapes
them for hours on end without mercy I
know it but no one else is allowed to
because in high school his raping pose I
mean yeah with human and then on the
flip side if we could break down the
language barrier which of course we
can't I don't think anyone speaks
elephants you know try to explain to
them the Harvey Weinstein scandal yeah
but but she got the Oscar right dude I
don't have the willpower for that human
beings elephant seal rape oh my god it's
bad you know what am I missing anything
for a commercial by the way cuz I don't
think we need to go to a commercial do
you guys want me to go to a commercial I
think what do we have is a commercial
it's a black rifle coffee it's not a new
one though right no all right so listen
black rifle coffee calm slash Crowder
entering the promo code Crowder you get
20% off they're doing buy a bag give a
bag right now with they're actually
giving bags to first responders and
medical workers did we get any of the
budget from the networks at all that's
okay of it here it's more than a handful
of mugs at least yeah let's see from
2010 to 2016 in 2010 the income amounted
to 732 million u.s. dollars and it'll go
to seven point two three but that's just
NBC yeah that's just NBC same or you
could say more likely I mean
if you look at the budget and the
funding in round one round two and round
aljazeera from the Young Turks
it's like towering over us it's not even
close yeah join mug club please if you
still want us here a quarantine to get
$30 off
I feel like Carl the intern could have
made a phone call with that budget right
with them you know they've been like
lady did you kill your husband right you
did it okay good got it did you both
take the fish tank cleaner together if
so would you submit to a random urine
slash blood test exactly I don't want to
I'm just so shaken up from trusting true
[Laughter]
by the way Apple podcast of course you
can subscribe there all the audio stuff
Crowder Biggs and you have $30 off with
the Month Club quarantine right now we
did as long evil okay yeah chat really
quickly and see what people are saying
yeah TD jakes is on TV good is black
with a grayish tint I don't bring that
up yeah it's a very grayish tint I hope
he's doing okay I've heard I've heard
nice things he could be horrible he
could be so we have a chat not be great
we have a chat from American patriot
hello to the latter with credit crew
thanks so much for the mug Club
quarantine month do you guys think there
is a possibility that this virus could
be used to remove constitutional rights
or a vehicle for socialism of course
absolutely I think so many people are
yearning for it what was remarkable to
me was there was a news outlet I can't
remember that photo it was a guy it box
it was an [ __ ] it was an [ __ ] at
box but I repeat myself
um and someone on CNN I believe we might
be able to post clip I don't necessarily
know that we need it because if you
doubt me on this and okay fine she said
well we can't do the same things here in
the United States because I'm unlike
China and unlike places like South Korea
we're much more free country and someone
at Fox that seems she confused South
Korea and North Korea no no no no no no
no no it doesn't only have to be Kim
jong-un but we have a right a
constitutional right to privacy South
Korea use private data on
phones to track monitor and then release
private information to the public in
South Korea so that others could avoid
them like Dinesh was talking about
socialism totality and socialism versus
democratic socialism rights are still
removed in that instance rights are
still removed when your private data or
any private information is released
publicly for the greater good I think we
need to do everything that we can I
think this is a legitimate purview of
government in the sense that this is a
national security issue it's a national
emergency that's why they exist however
they are not allowed to simply trample
over constitutional rights those are
always intact yeah absolutely and I
think the answer to the question too is
what Gavin Newsom said it's obvious like
this is a chance for them to launch
their progressive vision for the country
not only in the economy but in politics
he said that on the news I think it was
yesterday the day before and I think
anytime you look back at countries that
transition into socialism or end up in
an authoritarian state where they
weren't before it's something like this
that usually triggers it either a
horrific economic situation maybe
Germany has all the women - how much of
this is Bismarck just Bismarck - knows
don't you love that I had wet it had to
put on - you taped over the directions
open for us I don't know if that's
happening right now but this is the
scary part of the situation and I I am
all for government doing something like
this
if they can tell us that this will work
my problem is 15 days guys what you're
all for the government releasing private
data no I'm all for the government doing
a shutdown like they are right now like
you said that the purview of government
it's a national emergency the national
security issue I get it if they can tell
us that what we're doing will work
because we know what we're doing to the
economy there is no question that we're
damaging the economy what you did tell
me was that it was 15 days then you came
back and said we need another 30 tell
you oh yeah go ahead in one final point
in october/november when somebody comes
around and says somebody has kovat 19
somewhere in the world are we are we all
running for the bedrooms again are we
shutting down countries and economies
again because that is going to happen
right know that for a fact
yeah and they keep reporting they keep
reporting how many masks we have but we
don't know how many masks we need right
right and in that case I guess you said
running for the bedroom I mean I would
run for the bathroom well whatever
running general runs for the bedroom
German lineage have some spot on your
way out you know dude
thank your kid's gonna see this someday
I'm so sorry
no no the names have not been changed to
protect the innocent this is something
that I talked about you can go back and
watch it's hard to know exactly who to
trust so off of your point it's also the
numbers that they don't release when
they say look these are the death okay
who's dying not every life lost is
precious of course and I hate by the way
it's like one of those things where you
can never criticize a war or military
action without being accused of running
the troops now I do think that if we are
actually at war you should probably not
denigrate the troops when they come back
or spit on them like with Vietnam but if
you say you know what I'm not
necessarily sure that we can fix the
Middle East that doesn't mean that you
hate the troops and I hate it when
conservatives sometimes do that I also
hate if you say hey maybe this isn't the
right approach to the coronavirus that
somehow you don't care about the lives
lost the lives lost do matter what they
don't tell you when they're shutting
down the economy is that 90 something
percent in Italy 99 I believe in New
York it's 96 we've done it in previous
videos worth of links are there directly
99% of coronavirus patients in Italy had
pre-existing conditions were over the
age of 8 right yeah they should be
telling us that because that might
determine what we do it might determine
whether people will tolerate or even ask
for their rights to be removed in other
words they might say oh 99% of people
are over the age of 80 and have a
pre-existing condition otherwise than
the fatality rate higher than the flu
but well under 1% and with these
precautionary measures it can be lower
let's not shut down the entire economy
because I want my child to have a future
in this country that would be a
reasonable response if you're only given
half of the information that's a problem
and this comes back to another story
that I think is very important because I
talked about this quite a bit in this
same vein that it makes it really hard
to know what to trust so masks right now
this is a new story CDC they're now
saying that masks may be good
like we didn't know this who wants to
put the over-under on in two days
they'll say master okay they're good
maths are good masks or gloves man I'm
gonna mask that's what they're going
because really it's not about what's
best for you it's about the fact there
was a shortage yeah yeah and why does
that matter because of trying to cover
their own asses because the government
shipped out a lot of medical supplies
and replenish them no right now new
Trump says yeah L said Trump says new
recommendations on masks are upcoming
I mean I've spoken with doctors you I
know don't cut me off on this because I
don't want to give the wrong what's your
information on masks Gerald if you use
them improperly
okay all right exactly yes exactly now
sorry you just spirit you just ruined
the lead today no it's okay I don't care
but I actually I want to be very careful
because some people think that the
improper way to use a mask that you
can't reuse masks severed that's not
true I don't know that is not true
either because that's misinformation
that has been put out there by supposed
doctors so initially what were we told
you don't need masks at all I sit on
this show actually masks kind of help
and I talked about if you don't have a
mask you can make one out of a t-shirt
or a pillowcase I did a lot of research
on that they said don't take masks
because we have and then they said weak
but ever you healthcare worker need one
needs one right because there's a
shortage one what is it do maths not
work or is there a shortage just tell it
listen everyone should be wearing masks
but we screwed up so we don't have
enough masks in the private industries
going up to step in and save us so yes
masks help but please bear with us
because we suck we're in wouldn't have
been a problem yeah a problem is they
lie to the American public and so what
does that do it removes faith in
institutions just like with the media
and Russia and a false impeachment sham
I didn't mean actually shut up I just
wanna make sure they get the right
medical information as I could be sued
and I could it's already happened
to be an angry transgender doctor who
just looks like sub-zero yeah no they've
just been honest from the beginning the
same things that they're accusing
President Donald Trump of not being
honest right exactly I should have just
been honest writing well yeah do you not
and this is also I don't want to
attribute to a sinister motive but you
can simply chuck up to incompetence but
do you really believe that the CDC that
government health agencies suddenly woke
you think your head popped off the
pillow oh I was wrong about yeah I knew
when they said this why let's bring up
the study masks work we know beyond any
shadow of a doubt that masks do help
that's why they do them in a lot of
these Asian countries ensure when you
get on a Southwest flight and you see
someone with that and they're eating
hard-boiled eggs it's weird it's
unsightly but that's not like a wet
market it's just cultural differences
that we learn to tolerate yeah but the
reason if they told us if they didn't
tell us that masks work I can't think of
other any other motivation than thinking
that we can't handle that information
right like they lie to us to try to
because they don't think we can discern
like okay these people need them I
should not buy them right but yeah so
they basically are something we're
stupid well no I don't think that
they're assuming the American public is
stupid I think that they know the
American public will be manipulated by
the media in the sense that the media
will go out and have to buy all of the
rolls that's fair and that's what would
happen with the mass if the media comes
out and says we don't have enough masks
because Donald Trump's CDC shipped them
as opposed to Barack Obama yeah but
every and unfortunately these could be
life-saving measures in these dangerous
times and everyone's right that's the
American public are not stupid I will
say no yeah but unfortunately a lot of
the American public and particularly
some older portions of the American
public have believed in this idea of
objective journalism yeah and so I think
right now they have to think the CDC FDA
bruh Donald Trump they have to think two
three moves ahead because there's a
difference between what they want to say
versus what the media will say and by
the way I want this to be a campaign you
don't air the press briefing you don't
get a press badge that's why it matters
because Donald Trump could come out and
say hey listen we are building more
masks okay we need more masks but right
now give priority to health care workers
and then the media because they refuse
to run the briefing
then they write commentary saying Donald
Trump says he lied about masks because
they want to hurt his approval rating
when Donald Trump speaks directly to the
American people right now his approval
rating goes up and so what I do they
stop running the press briefings how
effective our masks I've talked about
this on-air specifically what two three
weeks ago again origen main they're
stepping up they're doing masks reusable
masks even a homemade mask particularly
from a cotton-blend
t-shirt or antimicrobial pillowcase okay
we have a link right there so hold it up
a little bit longer so that people can
this comes from NIH gov where they did a
study and you can find more information
on it they study to see what was most
effective at removing particles and
actually the most effective was I think
a vacuum bag cleaner in a dishtowel but
then people just couldn't breathe and
they were suffocated middle-ground
is a polyblend t-shirt followed by an
antimicrobial pillowcase because you
create two layers and it is 70%
effective at filtering small particles
now keep in mind a non n95 mask is 80
something percent effective anywhere
from 80 something percent to I've heard
as high as 94% I don't have the exact
numbers people might say 70% that's not
a lot here's the thing there's a
two-fold benefit with masks and I think
that it's something we could do in this
country by the way that would allow us
to again protect the most vulnerable
quarantine old people teach him how to
play xbox for all we care
give them their checks allow businesses
to open up identifying non-essential
businesses do the exact reverse of what
we're doing encourage the washing hands
proper hygiene and encourage people to
wear masks and use them properly in the
beauty is now you can sanitize masks as
well you can re sanitize masks they're
recyclable so not only we're going to
have more masks available we're going to
have more masks available in a way that
is reusable so 70 percent doesn't seem
like a whole lot two-fold benefit number
one we're finding out that the droplets
it's not an airborne virus it's not like
you know right mustard gas transmits
what the droplets are going
significantly further then they
initially thought there still seems to
be some testing a little bit of
disagreement I don't want to give you
false information masks almost
completely eliminate that okay so masks
almost they eliminate very effectively
the 70% is not about droplets going out
droplets going out masks are very
effective at stopping that so what
happens people who are carriers maybe
even people maybe even people who are a
sin
de Matic which by the way doesn't think
that should be silver lining right 25%
of people are asymptomatic so in other
words 90% of people when you total it up
have the coronavirus have no symptoms at
all yeah is that good news
instead it's 25% range of demotic which
means they can bring it to that 1% who
are they so there's some good in other
words the good news and then extrapolate
from make put together a strategy on how
to stay safe 25% of people don't have
any symptoms at all and the vast
majority have very mild symptoms so now
we know a lot of people are asymptomatic
don't know that they have corona virus
and we know that masks stop it from
spreading to other people everyone go
out and wear masks and then it's 70
percent effective at ingoing particles
that's not entirely but that being said
but if it's very effective for outgoing
particles and then 70 percent for the
next guy with ingoing particles guess
what that's more effective than a flu
vaccine what do we do with the flu
vaccine is to immunize 20% of the
American public so that we hopefully get
some kind of herd immunity that would be
huge it would be at least is probably
comparable to washing hands and like you
said don't use them improperly in other
words don't coffin your mask and give it
to someone else
yeah don't think that you can just put
your mask on and off and on and off and
it'll actually keep the bacteria out
from you now if you're a yes you coffin
to it and people get particles on it
then you take it off like this and
they're like well you just you just got
it on your hands and then you touched
your eye like just take it off well
there's the problem there is if you have
it yeah if you have it in you cough into
it now there's disease in that mask
well yeah you cough into it unless you
go hey smell this right the next person
is essential oils everything I heard
here's one of the things talking about
the American people they are we behave
very rationally for the most part right
there's plenty of examples where we
don't when people are panicked they
behave very irrationally and people
panicked and bought the stupidest things
in the world like toilet paper like
that's gonna help you in the zombie
apocalypse having toilet paper thing we
have a toilet paper stream coming up
next
do we okay very nice we do and it is
without a doubt the single most
offensive piece of content that we have
ever done that is saying something I'll
be on vacation that day yeah
but it's important that we creates that
kind of panickin so if you have a CDC or
you have the federal government come out
and say look guys like you said we need
to get these two first responders when
when get that done you will get the
masks we'll get whatever we need to you
that's much better than panicking people
and saying oh my god did you see all the
toilet paper is gone or all the masks
are gone right we behaved very
irrationally and we become stupid so
that's my yeah if we don't have all the
information the American public you know
panic even more right gonna go to
Facebook and find the information and
I'm mostly wrong there friend there's
one thing let me be really honest with
you guys okay because I'm always as
honest as I can you've heard me talk
about Everclear and masks before right
but I won't lie there's always a concern
let's say you have the inside scoop and
that's why you see insider trading
happening with people in Congress or you
know Republicans Republicans or
Democrats or you see it in media
sometimes were privy to information and
sometimes we want to make sure that we
get ahead of it that's what people do
and so they don't release that they
don't release that information that
could be what's going on with masks I
think that has happened with a lot of
people as it relates to some of the
emergency supplies I will tell you this
I was conflicted about telling you guys
about Everclear because I was like let
me go buy some Everclear right away but
I told you that day and then it was
available and only a week later did
Everclear start getting purchased off
the shelves because Everclear it can be
a sanitizer it's 90% alcohol it can be
used as a hand sanitizer it can be used
as a cleaner it's also something you can
drink if you need to and right now it's
significantly cheaper than hand
sanitizer now I have a couple of bottles
of Everclear so I'm fine but I wanted to
make sure that you guys know about this
the one area where I will say that I
don't tell you is my favorite cigar
people always ask and I don't say it
because it is it is available in very
limited quantities it's a seasonal
release and I haven't been able to get
ahold of the manufacturer that's one of
those things people want to know when do
I use my celebrity or my clout I want to
make sure that I have enough of my
favorite cigar before I recommend it
because I know I'll never be able to
find it again right so it's not that's
just my thing that's just my face okay
so I what everything is out in the open
if I were to go to confessional that's
what I would confess I've never told you
my favorite cigar I've told you but all
the cigars I like but what I really love
comes from like one portion of this
field and it's so good and it tastes
like I had never had
as a Canadian maybe they have them
Canada yeah but you said it tasted like
a like a snickerdoodle cookie yeah what
I person but kill all your children for
a lot of these cigars make it quick like
a large quantity of them like I need
okay so same thing with masks in other
words we've sifting beginning masks are
really important origin main they can do
a thousand a day we have those they are
reusable here's something else that'll
let you in on our use something in our
inner this is not news but I hope this
helps some people out there I use
something because I have a jujitsu gym
at home everyone comes out in trains and
it's in my garage I use something called
simp simple green simply green I think
it is it's a mat cleaner saloons rain
yeah no no it's not really pretty simple
green I think it's sold out you can't
find it now anyway I always have a few
gallons of it on hand because it kills
staph infection ringworm that's a big
thing and grappling now that being said
you can put two ounces of this into a
laundry load and it'll sanitize it it
can actually be used in industrial
settings and so that's what we've been
doing with our origin masks here at the
lattice Crowder studios you can find
this origin main is the company and we
put them in there wash them with this
simple green I think is what it's called
I don't know the exact name it's someone
good Matt clean simple green Johnny boy
you know what it is you can send it in
matte cleaner and your sanitizer masks
and they are reusable nice it does say
on there right coronavirus it kills it
does say that yeah it does say that
kills Corona but this is a novel
coronavirus keep in mind that 17% of all
influenza deaths every year all
influenza infection cases are some form
of corona virus but not this young but
some form so there you go
masks ever clear but I'm not gonna tell
you my favorite cigar just let me have
this one I love you there are other
cigars that I love this is not a lie in
my other top 10 list I love brick house
standard I love the wrong your cigars I
like almost anything from Espinoza I
like almost anything from AJ Fernandez I
love Padron's
I love the Oliver V Milani oh all these
are great cigars but I'm not gonna tell
you my favorite yeah we have a chat here
from
I'm not gonna tell anybody well never
mind no it's not about stick it is from
Matt in Florida what repercussions
should China face for unleashing this
pandemic on the world then he has a
couple of suggestions so force
forgiveness of debt mass tariffs
recognition of Taiwan what do you think
I think all of the above yeah I think
all the above and guess how it starts
with us here in the United States of
America let's be nationalists and
actually recognize that we have the
power to be the change we seek for
[ __ ] around the world so we can
recognize Taiwan we can try and exert
pressure to make sure that all
international committees and treaties
that have any anyone sign on to it
recognizes Taiwan we can make sure that
yeah there's some forgiveness of debt at
least of the amount of economic damage
that you've done to the global economy
and as far as the tariffs listen I'm not
a protectionist I just believe that they
should start playing fairly so in other
words it should be an equal
give-and-take with goods if they take
the tariffs off of ours if they start
importing fairly we should do the same
until then we mirror them exactly it's
matching intensity like my original
Brazilian jiu-jitsu instructors name was
furred bricio when I was going in I was
rolling really hard a little bit I was a
white thought we've talked less a little
bit because hey Steven I want to tell
you story okay
when you fight you match despise what I
said it when you fight this on the match
if you go switch people gotta be switch
people better be switch wish you luck
like a cookie in a no snickerdoodle
switch people be switch with you if you
roll spicy people not gonna be switch we
do that with China but certainly Taiwan
should be recognized if Brad Pitt can
get praised for seven years in Tibet I
think that we should certainly go out
and start hammering international commie
pricks for not recognizing a nation that
wants to separate the right well yeah
isn't it funny that the the punishment
that China gets is basically that they
just have to start playing fair do all
the crap you used to do right and get
away with it anymore now you have to be
normal like everybody else it'd be like
if a Chinese guy we're swirling another
shot another Asian guy but like if a
Chinese man were swirling a Taiwanese I
don't know if it I think they're all
probably about the same size small in
stature in general
swirling a Taiwanese person and then a
white American goes it is how do you
stop swirling him and then the left goes
race this is it cuz these Chinese what
are you he's because he's really another
Asian you're the nondescript Asian stop
raping the other Asian there's nothing
to do with race but we're accused of
being racist or ethnocentric yeah we do
have one more chattering Daniel here
says after the corona virus is over what
is the first thing you will do what is
the first thing that I will do gosh I
think I think I don't know I haven't
changed my life a hermit yeah that's
true
what are you gonna do I'm gonna go out
to guard eat with my wife probably you
know like we just want to go out I mean
she she likes to stay inside too so for
her this is like right this is the same
kind of thing as like Oh everybody has
to stay at home and I have no choice
she's throwing down her ponytail from
the windows I don't let her on the
second floor you know I don't know
honestly I really don't know I have no
idea my life hasn't changed maybe I'll
go out to eat like I'll go to a
restaurant which usually like I eat at
home anyway my wife cooks or we order
home we'll hope we'll go back to doing a
normal show I don't know I honestly like
the thing is we and my life is so dated
a making sure that we we hopefully serve
you guys adequately that's what we're
doing mug club Quarantine this is one
thing to its weight like you know what
we're doing twice those make an extra
dime right that's now what happens if
he's working harder we're working that's
you guys it I can't fix people in an ER
you can't right now I can make jokes and
talk about elephant seals it's true you
know we should do we should and not
usually I don't like your suggest you
don't yes but you say we should do like
a celebratory live show somewhere we
should that would be a lot of fun end of
quarantine live show committee yeah do
it right now and sir thank God we dodged
that please put the burgundy on wait a
second and it's a lot of us cried our
live on campus
okay we do have to get going by the way
of course you can hit the notification
bell if you are not subscribed to mug
club hit all notifications so that you
do get to see all of our content every
day and that's every day at 9 p.m.
Monday through Thursday I believe in of
course we still vote Saturday kind of an
asymmetrical times I guess for lack of a
better word Crowder bits Apple iTunes
and please listen
it's mug Club quarantine month we are
giving $30 off to everyone out there who
would like to join you'd have to join
right now you're trying it for a month
for free and if you want this content to
keep going things like after the
quarantine changed my mind things like
nada confronts more super videos which
by the way we can't do right now yes
that's one thing we're gonna do whenever
yeah that's what they will do there are
actually quite a few new confronts if
you can believe it but I'm just lying
and waiting him Zizi spoiler alert so
what you incur we do encourage you to
join will be of course here the next
show we'll be doing is live Monday
morning good morning Michael if it's
10:00 a.m. Eastern and then will be like
John Key will be live showing video
games on Tuesday so let me just tell you
this in closing personal story and I
talk about this is it's not necessarily
in line with the credit closes that I do
in the typical Thursday show but there's
kind of a rite of passage for men I had
a comic friend who said this that every
man has the right of past they have two
stories one is where they they drink too
much typically it's the story the tale
and one is where a man craps his pants
and he believed that if you didn't have
these stories and you were not a man I
don't have either of those good-sized
penis though so I figure it evens out
slightly above-average bell-curve little
little little higher just past center
that's how you know I'm telling the
truth
I play chess and trying to make you
think that so anyway every man typically
has a source I don't but as far as the
story of soil of crapping one's pants
today I came as close to this really as
ever in my life and it was a spiritual
experience let me explain to you every
morning my routine is a driver nowhere
in particular I Drive around in my car
and have block rifle coffee and
you have some kind of a seltzer water as
a palate cleanser because I really liked
savoring the coffee and then sometimes
okay listen
sorry so sue me that's my morning
routine I have kind of a loop that I do
for some reason this morning and I'll
get to the some reason at least my
suspicions I was driving away from home
ten met so I knew was ten minutes back I
know the typical loop is about 20
minutes at its furthest point I know and
I felt the Rauno and it was more than a
rumble it was like it was like okay this
is a problem right so let me just turn
around and I'm going back so the loop is
not the same street because I turn
around in a different portion like
seeing the sunrise because I'm up pretty
early yeah and as I loop back around to
come home I feel like okay I'm
definitely not going to a public
restroom because coronavirus right now
and I figured that it can climb up there
if we can't touch her eyes if there's
any irritation there I figure it's
somewhat porous and I don't want to roll
the dice at the 7-eleven you gonna be
the guy to get coronavirus ooh is that
no you don't wanna be that good patience
funny what if there is a guy over that's
that happened ah man sure like he's a
guy who everyone suspects is gay but
he's telling his wife no the doctor you
got your corona by your ass Oh
me must have been when I look at that
telephone pole so I didn't want to stop
at a public restaurant so I'm driving
home and thing okay I got time and then
on my loop home there's uh there's a
roadblock and because construction
workers can't go out and work it's not
moving at all Oh No
so three lanes has become one and I
imagine there's only I imagine it that a
demonic figure was put in the Hyundai
four cars in front of me because what
should at this point seven minutes just
turned into fifteen and I know this I
know some people are going to think this
is sacrilegious but I swear to you I was
sitting I was just praying like please
Lord don't let me grab my pants please
God don't let me crap my pants I've not
done it don't let me crap my pants and
then at a certain point I just realize
we're gonna minute fifteen sixteen
seventeen I kind of release myself to
the process and I said you know what
come away all your problems at his feet
I'm gonna stop because the lactic acid
threshold there's a lot
got threshold for the pucker they're
people just like a bicep you know
there's a certain point you can't do any
more curls right at a certain point that
it's like opening the the pressure
chamber in sphere and which was one with
sam neill underwater was it sphere
sam neill going so I I said okay lord I
am not in control of this whatever
happens happens and then I thought for
sure that I did because there was some
sense there was relief there was relief
and I was i sat there for another five
minutes mrs. Hyundai and I made it home
and then I still ran to the bathroom
because I figured that lady only you
know released a certain amount to make
it bearable until I got home but I I
should you not I got home I went to the
bathroom to check the damage because I
wanted to make sure they threw anything
out Apple an Al Roker and I check my
sweatpants and it was like Shadrach
Meshach and Abednego
there was no poop I didn't poop myself
they didn't burn in the fire I looked
and I was what so for some reason and
then by the way I took hit I went so in
other words it wasn't like I didn't have
to go anymore and I miss my chance it
was so painful that's why you saw me
with the pepto-bismol I think was just
like after giving birth there's a
certain level of remaining inflammation
auxilary inflammatory markers compared
and what happened there was I got I did
we have that overlay it was clean as a
whistle
when I tell you what and he took a
picture of Wow and always is looking for
a big sign sometimes with God he the
Lord works in mysterious ways and it's
the small things and so I still don't
have a story of crapping my pants which
I guess means I'm not a real man but I'm
eternally grateful thank you very much
join Mudd Club hashtag Mudd Club
quarantine promo code quarantine $30 off
at ladder with credit calm / month club
we will see you at 10 a.m. Eastern
Monday morning
[Music]
[Music]